To make a 15% mixture, we would need 4 liters. If you got that one right, that's
amazing work. You've really mastered how to solve these system problems. If this
one gave you trouble, that's okay. Stay with me to figure out what might have
gone wrong. The question asks for how much of the 15% mixture we should use. So
that's going to be our variable, x. We start with 10 liters of a chemical
mixture that is 8% water. So that's going to be my percent 1 and volume 1. For
percent 2 and volume 2, I'm adding 15% of x liters of solution. And for my final
percentage, I know the mixture needs to be 10% water. I don't know my final
volume. But if I remember back from the bucket, if I pour in one volume, and I
pour in another volume, that gives me my total volume. So I poured in 10 liters
first, and then I poured in x liters. This must mean that the total volume is 10
plus x. I can use that here. Now we have one equation with one variable, and we
can solve for x. I multiply my terms together, and then I distribute the 0.10.
Next, I subtract 0.8 from both sides. I'm moving my constant terms to the right.
This means that I must move my x terms to the left. I subtract 0.1x from both
sides to get 0.05x equals 0.2. And finally I divide by the coefficient of x, to
get x is equal to 10 liters.